everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve best time to buy and sell a stock
with a cool down and this is actually a
very interesting problem and a very
challenging problem but honestly i'm
gonna make this problem look like a joke
today and that's not because i'm really
smart it's honestly only because i know
how to draw a picture i'm sure you guys
know how much i like drawing pictures
for leak code problems and how helpful
they are and this problem is a perfect
example of why exactly that is so let's
get into it we are given an array of
prices the price at index i just
represents the price of a given stock on
the ith day and our goal is to maximize
the profit that we can achieve and the
complicated part is that actually we can
make as many transactions as we like we
can buy a stock and then sell a stock
but there are a couple restrictions the
main restriction here is that we can't
buy a stock and then sell the stock on
the next day we have to have at least
one day in between called the cool down
day now we could have one cool down day
but we could actually have multiple cool
down days if we really want to right
because we have a choice of how many
transactions we can complete and the
other restriction here is that if we buy
the stock let's say on index zero right
we buy it for price one we can't just
buy it the next day as well right we
can't just have uh infinitely many we
can only have one share at a time
basically that's what they're trying to
get at right we can't buy and then buy
and then buy we have to buy and then
sell and then rebuy so in this example
with this array of prices the result
happened to be three three is the max
profit we could get and these are the
decisions we would make to result in the
output three we buy on the first day we
buy for one we sell for two that's a
profit of one so so far we have a profit
of one we cool down on day three so we
cool down we buy it for zero the next
day and then sell it for two so that's a
profit of two so the total profit was
three so not too bad but the real uh
complicated part about this problem is
that we have so many choices that we
could make and that can get really
complicated unless of course you draw a
picture so let me show you how with
drawing a picture we can solve this
problem in linear time so like i said
there's a lot of decisions to make so
let's try to draw out those decisions
the first main thing here is we can
either buy or we can sell and we can
only sell if we have already bought the
stock before so when we start out
at this array right we start at day zero
at this point at the beginning of the
array are we buying or are we selling of
course we're buying because we don't own
the stock yet so we can't sell it so
that's one part of the state that we
have to kind of keep track of are we
buying or are we selling and it's not
too hard because it's just a boolean
right it's true or false and initially
we're buying so you know we have a
choice at index one right we can buy so
of course one decision is buy if we buy
the stock on day zero it costs one so if
we do buy what's our total profit so far
well buying costs money so our total
profit so far if we buy is gonna be
negative one now are there any other
decisions we can make other than buying
well we definitely can't sell yet we
don't own anything but we can definitely
do a cool down now if we do a cool down
then our profit is going to be zero so
far and by the way let me just draw a
little zero up here because when we
initially started our profit was also
zero okay now on the left path of the
decision tree what choices can we make
now can we also buy and do a cooldown
well we already bought we can't buy
again we have to sell now technically we
don't have to sell but that definitely
is one of our choices the other choice
of course is cool down so as you can
kind of tell now
we always have a choice of cooling down
right the the main choice that we're
going to be determining is are we buying
or are we selling the other choice can
always be cool down we don't have to do
anything but if we do sell on the second
day you can see on the second day the
price is two so uh by selling we're
basically doing a plus two operation
right initially we had negative one
we're doing a plus two so that means our
total profit if we sell so far is going
to be positive one so that's pretty good
now of course if we cool down the profit
is going to stay the same meaning
negative one now let's quickly draw the
decisions on the right side of the tree
if we cool down
then we can't sell because we haven't
bought anything yet so the same
decisions will be present as you know
the original decisions basically buying
cooldown over here and the other
decision is going to be buying so here
if we buy we saw that initially we had
zero as the total profit but if we buy
on the second day that'll be a minus two
operation so our total profit so far
will be minus two if we cool down of
course it'll just stay zero so now we
get to a kind of interesting case
uh after we have already sold then what
are our decisions can we buy and then
also have a cool down well the answer is
no and the reason is because remember
after selling we are forced to have at
least one cool down day right after
selling so basically just pretend like
we skipped a day right we had a forced
cooldown day right that's our uh one
decision and we we can't make any other
decisions here right this is our
decision we're forced to do a cool down
after selling but after doing that uh we
know our profit is going to stay the
exact same plus one after doing that
though then we do have a choice of
buying or having another cool down day
so we can buy or we can have another
consecutive cool down day if we have
another cool down day of course our
profit is going to stay the exact same
plus one but if we buy well first what
day is it it's the fourth day now it's
uh the price is zero so if we buy it's
going gonna cost us zero i wish i could
buy stocks for a zero price but in this
case of course if it costs zero then our
total profit is just going to stay the
same so we can stay at plus one now
let's continue on this path last
decision we can make is either selling
or having another cool down day of
course if we sold well
we're on the fifth day the last day it
costs the prices to so we'll make a
profit of plus two we were already at
plus one so one plus two is going to be
three that's going to be our total
profit if we took this chain of
decisions right if we bought sold had a
cool down then bought and sold again
this is what the profit would be of
course every path in this decision tree
is going to have a different number
right for the total profit so far and of
course we want to return the maximum and
by the way if we had the cooldown day
instead on the last day then our profit
would stay the same it would be plus one
as opposed to plus three and just
imagine that you know every leaf node of
this tree has some different number and
among all of those we want to return the
maximum so among these two decisions
between three and one of course the
value we are going to return when we
implement the solution recursively the
value we're going to return is going to
be the plus three we're just going to
take the maximum of these two and return
the max so i really hope looking at this
picture makes the solution
understandable for you the downside to
the solution though is the time
complexity you can see that the height
of the tree that we're making is going
to be n where n is the size of the
price's array and the number of
decisions at every point we can make is
up to two decisions so the overall time
complexity is going to be 2 to the power
of n but we can actually use a very
simple dynamic programming technique
called caching in this case and by doing
that we can reduce the time complexity
to big o of n the reason why is because
the key for the caching that i'm going
to be doing is one going to be the index
right the index of what position we're
at in the price is array the second
key i'm going to be using is a boolean
for buy or sell i want to know if we're
buying or are we selling it's a binary
decision so we can just use a boolean
for that right if we take this key value
how many possible values could it be
well the index i there's n different
possible values for it this uh by or
cell state is going to be two different
states for it because it's just a
boolean right so if we take n times two
uh we basically get two times n
right which we know is just can reduce
to big o of n so
in this case if we use caching the time
complexity will be big o of n the memory
complexity will also be big o of n
because we are caching if you're not
familiar with caching i'll be explaining
it right now as i go into the coding
solution okay so now let's write out the
code you can see i already wrote out a
few things one is just a comment kind of
explaining what we're going to be doing
we're going to keep tracking of the
state whether we're buying or we're
selling if we buy we're just going to
increment the index by one if we sell
we're going to increment the index by
two reason is because we remember we
have to take a cool down day after we
sell and remember we are going to be
using caching a dynamic programming
technique so the easiest way to do a
cache is just use a hashmap so that's
what i'm doing here with python and just
a comment what i'm going to be using as
the key value of this hashgraph is going
to be the index i that we're at in our
prices array and a boolean which is
called buying it's going to be true if
we're in a buying state and it's going
to be false if we're in a selling state
and the value of the hashmap is just
going to be the max profit associated
with this key value so now let's get
into it i'm going to be writing out a
recursive function dfs i'm going to be
writing the function inside of our root
function
because it's just easier that way we
don't have to pass in every single
parameter we don't have to pass in the
prices array we don't have to pass in
our dp cash we only have to pass in
our index and whether we're buying or
we're selling so
first thing with recursive functions i
like to do is just write out the base
case so we know that the main base case
is going to be if index goes out of
bounds so basically if index is greater
than or equal to the length of the
prices array i didn't really cover this
base case in the drawing explanation but
i think it's pretty self-explanatory if
we go out of bounds basically if we have
an empty array of prices what are we
going to return well we can't make any
profit off of that so we're going to
return zero okay so that's great and the
other base case i just want to quickly
mention is the case that if this pair of
values this i and buying pair has
already been computed before so
basically if this is in our dp hash map
initially our dp hash map is empty but
if this is in our dp hash map then we
assume that the max profit associated
with this key has already been stored so
then we can return that right so in dp
we can just use this key value and then
return whatever that max profit we
stored was okay so now for the actual
decision that we can make and remember
that decision that we make is going to
depend on only one thing what state are
we in are we buying or are we selling so
it's a binary estate right so if else so
let's start with the buying so we know
in the buying state we can do two things
we can buy or we can have a cool down
day right what's going to be the profit
the max profit associated with each of
these well if we buy we're going to
recursively call dfs at index i plus 1.
and what's the state going to be are we
gonna leave buying as the same of course
not because if we just bought then we're
in the opposite state we're in the not
buying state so in python this will
literally just take that boolean value
and negate it or in other languages you
could just do like the exclamation mark
but i'll leave this as is so that's how
the recursive call is gonna work pretty
straightforward but the only thing is if
we bought doesn't that affect our profit
so far remember that's what i was
keeping track of so if we bought we have
to subtract the price of what we just
bought we bought the index on
day i so that's what we have to subtract
from the total this will tell us what
the max profit we can get from the
remaining array starting at the not
buying state and this will tell us how
much it actually costed us to get to
this state in the first place similarly
we'll do the cool down state which is
slightly easier because all we have to
do is do i plus one and in this case the
buying state actually stays the exact
same because we did not buy so we're
we're still in a buying state and we
don't have to subtract anything because
we didn't spend any money and last but
not least don't forget to cash the
results so now we have our result so i'm
going to use our key value i and buying
and remember we took two decisions among
these two decisions what do we want to
know we want to know which one created
the max profit for us so let's just take
the max of buy and cool down and then
assign that to dp so this is where we
are actually caching so if we cache the
solution and then we try to recompute
that solution up above then we're going
to end up returning it instantly rather
than going through all the recursive
calls over again okay so that's really
the bulk of the problem last thing we
have to do is handle the sell case so if
we
sell then we're going to do dfs
and remember if we sell we're actually
going to increment the index by two
because we have to take a cool down day
and if we sell we also have to negate
the value of the boolean and you know
you can do what's readable for you if
you want to change this to you know set
the buying state to true now uh you know
whatever is readable for you i prefer
just setting it to the negation um but
instead of subtracting the price like we
did with buying we want to actually add
the price because if we sold that means
we made some money so we can
you know add the profit of this uh
notice i forgot the s up above um and
yeah so that's one decision and the
other decision is just the cooldown
decision which we can literally just
copy and paste from up above because the
cooldown is just skipping the day and
it'll be the same in both cases and i'm
going to copy the dp assignment up above
because the only difference uh if we
sold is we're going to take the max of
sell and the cool down day and if you
want to save like one line of code here
you can probably just take one of the
cool down functions
move it outside of the if else statement
and then delete the other cooldown which
i guess i'll do for you but i don't
think it's really that important but
yeah once that's done what do we want to
return we want to return whatever the
max profit was we luckily stored that in
our dp so we can just return uh just
like this and believe it or not that
really is the entire function but we
don't have to we don't want to forget to
actually call that function so let's
call our dfs starting at index zero and
initially the buying state is true
because we are buying when we start out
so let's run this to make sure that it
works and as you can see on the left yes
it works and it is pretty efficient so i
really hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it really
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching